i find it very ironic that many of my
biggest fans do not live their lives
anywhere close to what i'm saying and
let me actually point this very directly
to my community because i live in the v
friends discord all the time and i can
tell you right now some of my biggest
fans holding seven tokens are incredibly
not civil when somebody comes in and
tries to bring negativity there is no
compassion it's [ __ ] you troll get the
[ __ ] out of here i'm not perfect
somebody comes in and asks a question
they need to be treated with a civil
answer like i'm doing it if i'm in there
treating someone who's descending voice
with respect we've got to learn this
they got to read 12 and a half
you talk that garyvee [ __ ] you don't
live that garyvee [ __ ] you don't live it
on the kindness and humanity you don't
live it on the empathy and about that
and i don't say that on stage to come up
here like i'm good i'm coming on stage
saying cut that [ __ ] out i promise you
it's real